The SSL record protocol provides
two services for SSL connections.
For confidentiality, the handshake
protocol defines a share seeker key
that is used for
symmetric encryption of SSL payloads.
For message integrity, the handshake
protocol also defines a share seeker key
that is used to form a message
authentication code or MAC.
This figure shows the overall
operation of the SSL record protocol.
The first step is fragmentation.
Each upper layer message
is fermented into blocks.
Next, conversion is applied.
Then the next step is to compute
the message authentication code
over the compressed data.
Next, the compressed message,
plus the MAC are encrypted
using symmetric encryption.
The final step is to prepend a header,
which includes the version and
length fields.
Know that there's no distinction that's
made among the various applications
that might use the SSL record protocol.
The counting of the data created
by these applications is opaque
to the SSL record protocol.
The record protocol transmits
the data in a TCP segment.
The receiving end decrypts the data,
verifies it, decompress it,
and reassemble the data and deliver
it to the higher layer protocols.